what's up babies welcome to an episode
of get close I'm your co-host Geo and
I'm Bart and uh what what is that you
and I'm Bert you know my favorite
picture is that one right there
it's you and me right next to each other
as kids yeah and you have this picture
is this face oh wait where oh and then I
have this one on the duck
and it's CUNY because I've seen Tyco
make both of those faces yeah and he
literally is like I thought it was that
one up there with the pink shirt and I'm
like I've seen that one oh yeah a little
like hmm
smug yeah it's cute he's like exactly in
between us yes
um
if you like
had a chance to trade
bodies yeah with who uh so that's the
question would you rather trade bodies
with taika or with me for a day
trade bodies yeah with taika well your
body just seems like it produces the
most foul [ __ ] like what like I mean
your feet are gnarly like your butt is
gnarly your [ __ ] mouth is gnarly so
you would want to definitely experience
like what it's like to be a specimen
there's like the [ __ ] black [ __ ]
coming out of your ears when they get
clogged like I don't know man I mean I
don't bleed out of my genitals
are you sure about that fine you got
itchy genitals they're really itchy you
got eczema genitals I know
um either that or would you rather stuff
yourself into a little four foot man oh
my God man
I think I'd be taika just I could feel
like what it would like he just has so
much energy and he's like we always joke
around like how many steps you think
that kid we need to get him a snap
tracker this guy's running around 24 7.
I need to know how many steps this four
has if you had to guess how many steps
you think
I think at least double so I'm thinking
like twenty thousand thirty thousand I'm
thinking like forty thousand honestly 40
000. so because you have to also
consider his legs like his legs are Itty
Bitty so one of my steps is probably
like four of his because he could run
man he runs everywhere yeah the times
when I play like tag with them like I
can run faster obviously and but the
pace that he keeps going he can just
keep going forever and I'm like oh my
God I'm so tired holy [ __ ] that's crazy
because you are a lot for me like you're
always ahead in steps than I am yeah
like you're always like a thousand over
than me and I'm like how the [ __ ] we
like literally are next to each other
all day I'm like how did you get a
thousand ahead of me
and I think you move a lot too and I
don't realize it but I don't see it
I mean or at least I don't recognize it
but you're [ __ ] moving so goddamn
much right now probably taking care of
your ass [ __ ] like getting you water
what are your steps right now around
doing all kinds of stuff let me see
five thousand nine hundred five thousand
one hundred so just about 800 ahead of
you yeah were you always like this is a
kid well moving around yeah oh yeah you
you were like taika
um I think I had crazy 80d where I
didn't have control over it so now like
I get to use it in my creative space
yeah and it really helps me like think
outside the box and stuff
um but when I had when I was a kid like
one of the the most uh memorable moments
of me getting yelled at is in fifth
grade in Mrs bonnet's class and I
remember I was sitting in my seat
listening to her [ __ ] talk all boring
some [ __ ] boring ass [ __ ] and I
remember going like this
I closed my eyes my eyes open and I hear
but what are you doing and my hand was
in the turtle tank playing with the
turtle across the room and I was like I
looked around like what what the [ __ ]
I put the turtle down
and then I'm like wait but it was in
water yeah it's like [ __ ] Turtle
juice and I go and I go back to my seat
and I just remember like
um like holy [ __ ] how did I teleport
there so I just knew I always had a lot
of energy and kind of like taika right
where he's like he's like going crazy
and like sometimes we'll just tell me
chill chill he tells us that now yeah
and he's like chill pickled chill yeah
what do you mean what do you mean
because he doesn't know but I'm like
when you're waving a [ __ ] stuffed
animal right you're gonna knock this cup
over knock that cup over so he just has
too much energy in this room right now
that it can cause damage because it's
hard to explain all that to a kid and I
think that's uh how I've been because
I'm like oh man I remember like a lot of
like
um parents I mean a lot of teachers
telling my mom or even my mom's friends
like when they would like babysit me
they're like he's just too much
and it's hard to describe too much you
know until you have too much yeah yeah
[ __ ] dude
yeah no you're not like that now
obviously but [ __ ] hey now I remember
because you
you've uh kind of like brought back a
memory yeah of like an embarrassing
moment I don't know why this moment
sticks out in my brain so much but I was
in um first grade
and miss pendergrass's
that's her name my teacher's name and
she was reading about
um like these different I don't even
know what the book is anymore but I knew
there was like a Mrs Chatterbox I'm sure
it has a moral to it right because all
kids stories do
um and we were on the carpet and it was
reading time and she was reading it to
us and then she called me Mrs Chatterbox
in front of the whole class and that
embarrassed me so much I was so
embarrassed that she called me out
because you talk too much yeah because I
was talking I think she called me Miss
Chatterbox and that crushed me why did
it Crush you I don't know maybe because
I think I really liked her as a teacher
oh she's she's pretty and like I
remember now thinking back to how I'm
going to describe her she's gonna sound
[ __ ] ridiculous but she had like
really long pretty hair and she had like
little bangs and stuff and she always
liked wearing like pinks and blues and
like she I remember her wearing this
like sweater like this knit sweater and
like she would make her makeup match her
clothes
that she sounds like that um you know
the older lady that she was young um I
know but the older lady's style and uh
something about Mary like that the one
has a crazy ass tan
neon green eyeliner she didn't have a
tan but yeah she was like Slender and
young and like really pretty
um and she would wear like blue eyeliner
with like pink [ __ ] eyeshadow and
[ __ ] she was sweet she was a sweet lady
but when she called me that like I was
crushed I was like oh my God why do I
why does that stick with me so much
isn't that interesting maybe is that an
identity that you didn't think you had
are you you'd ever thought you never saw
yourself as a like a very talkative
person maybe maybe maybe that was like
my first taste of like getting put in my
place because after that like it was
just like every [ __ ] teacher I had I
was like [ __ ] chatting it up you know
for the yearbook
um did you ever get voted like you know
there's like most likely to succeed
whatever dude I don't know what my issue
was in high school but like I didn't
care and I wasn't trying to be
rebellious like I wasn't doing it on
purpose but I had zero motivation to be
in my yearbook so I didn't even take my
senior class I didn't yeah but they
don't um it's not up to you oh no all
your peers vote you in no I wasn't that
cool I did a good job of like not being
cool oh no all of my yearbooks it was
either most humorous or most talkative
the humorous one I'm like okay I get it
because I try to be funny in class
because class is so [ __ ] boring
someone's got lighten it up the most
talkative ones I remember like I have
one there's a picture of me like holding
a phone it was like me and this other
chick oh was that staged
like they're like here talking yeah
because once you win it they go okay
we've got to take that picture for the
yearbook so was it a [ __ ] landline
yeah it was a landline with the coil so
I'm taking a picture and I remember
seeing the chick and I'm like oh yeah
for sure you're most talkative like
she's the one that likes to talk to
everyone
um she kind of has that uh Sherry Cola
energy oh okay right and then for me I'm
like
can you imagine me with Sherry Cola
energy no no right I was like why were
you most talkative I don't know but
people voted me for that I'm like well
great [ __ ] I think it was like uh junior
high like seventh or 8th grade what and
I'm like what are you serious what do
they classify as talkative like is it
that you know know that would be more
popular maybe I'm just popping up like
just starting conversations and stuff so
I can see maybe like in in elementary
school maybe I'm like way more physical
you know like me bringing my friend like
cat to school and stuff like that but
that's Elementary you said but you said
this happened in intermediate it yeah so
I think maybe that the physical went to
me starting constantly starting
conversation hey what's up what's going
on really can you picture me as like a
[ __ ] extrovert no no way right well I
don't I don't know if talkative yeah no
I can't like me sparked in a random
conversation no what's going on did he
catch you off guard or were you like
yeah yeah no that's like when I saw the
chick my counterpart
I was like oh yeah for sure and I'm like
now when you saw the counterpart but
when you got voted that position because
or they just surprised you and they just
pull you out of school and that same day
they tell you they take a picture
what yeah oh [ __ ] like hey Bart you're
like you're this and I was like are you
serious honestly I don't even know how
they get that like do you vote somewhere
yeah I think all the all the class like
rights they nominate right and then I
think that's the first pass then the
second pass they're like the top three
most talkative is Bank blank blank and
now you vote on those three I don't even
think I even did that maybe I was absent
that day or something but I don't recall
any of that I [ __ ] hated High School
and I oh uh junior high was a weird
space I didn't hate High School I hated
myself in my high school
what do you mean
um like my first high school I went to
it was [ __ ] dope it was a really good
school like
I always talk about it do you know about
did you know it was dope when you were
in it or is it because you traveled so
much that you're like [ __ ] man that was
a [ __ ] it was dope when I was in it and
this is Cerritos High yeah Cerritos High
School it was at that time I think
things changed but so what I really
loved about my high school is one it was
crazy diverse like culturally diverse so
like on culture day all the clubs would
set up like little stands and stuff so
all the kids can like go around the quad
and like talk to people yeah so there's
a Filipino Club Indian club Mexican club
like there's all these cultures right
yeah and it was so like intermixed that
you'll see white people in the Indian
club or you'll see a Mexican in the
Chinese Club because they're just tight
so they're like oh my best friend is
that me was that are you shouting me out
right there maybe yeah but you'll have
like because their people are best
friends yeah so they'll be in those
clubs yeah so that was [ __ ] cool
um and I remember going on wow this is
[ __ ] diverse this is [ __ ] dope and
then like prior to that you were in
junior high yeah okay and then you go to
uh like um you'll see skater groups and
then they'll be like like an Asian dude
in there you know you know so I always
thought that was [ __ ] dope or you'll
see like an Asian gang and you'll see
like some white dude with bangs and [ __ ]
Doritos had Asian Kings yeah yeah and
you'll see like Asian gangs oh yeah you
have like it was crazy it was like
um it was uh you know when you see when
you watch a high school movie and you
see the Trope right like The Jock that
was it the artist the whatever you saw
that at the school except it was a
realistic reflection do they have movies
like that still like High School movies
yeah like uh Spider-Man Tom Holland was
he in high school yeah he's not
surrounded and it's not like a a high
school movie it's just about a teenager
yeah but it said in a high school and
you go oh that's the jock that picks on
people oh got it got it got it right
right okay good right like yeah even
even the guy that the Indian guy the guy
that hates Spider-Man but it's the
biggest yeah like you go oh he's the guy
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah
our school was such a was like that but
a realistic reflection of the time in
the 90s yeah so you'll see oh the cholos
everyone [ __ ] white teas press
Dickies bald head or whatever
um or yoga and you'll see like oh the
skinheads you know everyone has a
[ __ ] Neo-Nazi symbol tatted on to
only wear wife beaters
um and so it was a reflection of the
time of our tropes so not that movie
tropes but it was like the movie version
of our tropes and so that was really
cool to see also even intermingling and
that seeing like white dudes with bangs
and Asian gangs and stuff like that
and then uh and like we would have like
in and out truck day McDonald's truck
day Power 106 would come to our school
to uh perform or do whatever and I was
like oh this is like
[ __ ] like legit [ __ ] you know and
then um our breakdowns Crews were doing
like the moves that you see on TV not
people trying to do those but they were
like doing those moves
and I was just and then uh we had a dude
go to the NFL and then we had a guy that
was a pro skater at the time at our
school so it was just like
um
it felt like this Heist and how do you
know all this like it's just word gets
around it goes oh like uh I think his
name is Jermaine something he's like oh
Jermaine's gonna go to the NFL you're
like oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] this word
gets around you know and then like oh
you were most talkative I don't know
anything about any of my [ __ ] peers
or anything I didn't give a [ __ ] oh
maybe anybody oh something Castro
whatever oh you just gospel you guys
have heavy uh school spirit
at Cerritos yeah so they're in the pep
rallies man they go all out the whole
schedule changes like they'll be like uh
you know first second third fourth fifth
period all the periods all of a sudden
go from like I don't know like an hour
to only 30 minutes long so that so the
pep rally can be it's full 30 minutes or
an hour wow yeah pep rally schedule and
uh even like homeroom right like you
know in homeroom in this in in those
movies it's like good morning Cerritos
High School today is yeah today is April
24th Tuesday and we all know but when
you hear that going on just in the end
how cool yeah like you know like um
Beverly Hills 90210 yeah it was like
that like you know what Brian Austin
Green he's the school DJ right and he's
like saying those things it was like is
that in high school or were they in a
college I was in high school it was like
that like coming up this Friday don't
forget it's Sandy's Hawkins It's not not
unless it's not too late to whatever
whatever make sure you can figure out
your crush
like you know like it's always like that
and it's like shout outs to Mrs Barbara
whatever she beat cancer so if you see
her around campus don't forget to say
what's up you know like that kind of
[ __ ] all right yeah it's like it's like
I thought that was just movie [ __ ]
exactly until I went to this high school
and I'm like dude this is [ __ ] like
the movies or football uh games pack
bleachers
um every single theme that we did was
like legit the way the movies are and I
was like man this is [ __ ] cool how
long did you last there
oh man only like a year and a half
because my [ __ ] dumbass was such a
troublemaker I got in so much [ __ ]
trouble
um I literally had detention like every
day
and uh
yeah I had detention every day ended up
getting kicked out and so that's why I
hated I didn't hate High School I hated
myself in high school because I didn't
even feel like I uh
um
was able to take out
yeah but is this in retrospect or was it
as soon as you were kicked out you're
like [ __ ] I'm so disappointed in Bart
the whole [ __ ] step of the way
yeah man like we had this thing called
Model United Nations have you guys heard
of it so a Model United Nations is
almost imagine what it is it's almost
like uh the United Nations like debate
right so what's pretty cool is uh you
have to be an honors history class to
get in it and I was lucky enough to get
into honors history I was a Model United
Nations and what ends up happening is if
you have a conference
um every person that's going to the
conference gets assigned a country and
gets assigned a position
right so like let's say uh you might be
Vietnam
and you might be pro-child labor the
other person is America anti-child labor
when you go to these conferences it's
all the model United Nations from all
the other schools so you don't even know
these people from all the other schools
they could be from Pennsylvania they
could be from New York Texas whatever
everyone comes dressed uh as if you're
going to Model United Nations so it's
suit and tie and all that stuff and you
sit there and then uh was your mom super
proud of you because I feel like anytime
your mom sees you in a suit and tie it's
like oh he's doing big [ __ ] I don't know
she probably hated my Guster in this
period and um and you don't go as
Giovanna you don't go as bar you go as
your country so your placard literally
says that will say Vietnam and then so
when you're in there what was your
country uh I forgot but like every every
conference you're a different so you
exercise that part of your brain you
know because sometimes your pro child
labor percentage against child labor
sometimes you're Pro oil drilling
something against oil drilling but it
exercises your brain and it makes you
research facts on why that country has
to do that right so when you go to these
conferences you're sitting there and
it's like uh Vietnam or whatever and
you're talking to someone
um you're like uh Vietnam will like to
motion to do whatever so it's literally
like an actual conference group and then
um they'll be like Uruguay opposes it's
like that and there's like a moderator
that's like you know like because you
can't just speak out a term you sound
like a [ __ ] geek dude yeah but I was
like dude this is [ __ ] but it's
actually really dope this is [ __ ]
dope right like it's really preparing
you for the real world especially if you
want to go into [ __ ] politics and all
that [ __ ] but my [ __ ] dumbass uh I
think for one conference I was actually
pro-child labor and of course I have to
make a whole joke out of it so when I
went up to give my speech I think I was
talking about how like um like uh the
only way to get like Victoria's late
Victoria's Secret lace to be that
beautiful and that intricate you need
small little fingers so I was like
imagine if like you use adult fingers to
sew the bras like people's nipples
pop out whatever and I just see all the
Jaws dropping like all my homies are
[ __ ] cracking the [ __ ] up laughing
whatever and then the teacher in the
room's like get out
just immediately just get out so this is
the teacher that's the moderator not
necessarily your home yeah it could be a
teacher from a different school right
because it's always traveling around
like games like like [ __ ] football
games right it's like you're traveling
around and I remember going outside
[ __ ] smoke cigarette with the homies
I'm like dude what the [ __ ] is going on
man in high school yeah I've been
smoking so I'm like smoking cigarettes
[ __ ] stressful [ __ ] I'm trying to
just [ __ ] trying to represent Vietnam
in this place and then obviously all you
know and it's all expecting so in that
and I have to research to write funny to
write funny [ __ ] you know
um because I found like Victoria's
Secret was like manufacturing Vietnam
and all that stuff so I was like it's
based in reality yeah and um but me
like
the moment I got kicked out I'm like
[ __ ] I lost such a dope opportunity
thanks you knew right off the bat right
off the bat I'm like why do I have to be
like this why can't I be like that
[ __ ] geek right there we just do a
[ __ ] good job I'm just talking [ __ ]
yeah man look at these [ __ ] nerds
[ __ ] nerds like maximizing their
brain doing such a good job but probably
gonna go to [ __ ] Harvard after this
it was it was just you being suppressed
so much
because the jokes isn't like a thing and
maybe it's just your eight your wild ass
add
maybe I think I just see how it was your
parents
or is it because you're so repressed
that like now you're just you need to
get it all out do you ever have this
feeling like let's say you're driving on
the road right
and you you see a fork on the road
this side is a straight line
this side goes like this
which which road are you gonna go on
clearly the straight line why
because I just don't want to hassle with
all the [ __ ] this I know that's the
problem the minute I see that I always
go oh there it is so I have to go
so like that's what that that's that's
my problem why I don't know that's my
problem so like I see like my position
right even now you do that oh [ __ ] yeah
give me an example now I get paid to do
it give me an example oh just to be
funny guys literally everything JK news
will talk about [ __ ] or whatever it's
like there's a serious topic or
someone's vulnerable I can't wait to
dunk on the [ __ ] it's so [ __ ]
fun
okay I think it was just right yeah even
like the like the the famous like JK
news joke were like I don't know he
talks about Anthony or whatever and I
was like oh but even when it's like
obviously I hear I see two choices like
oh whoa why would they do that but
that's not that
you know so for me it's like I just see
every time there's a something that
happens two roads I'm like this one's
way more fun but the minute I take that
one I'm like oh man
why'd I do that and I got [ __ ] kicked
out look what happened oh my God and I
see taika having the same thing too yeah
he's always picking the funner choice of
the two I
and it actually
takes that means you're thinking so I
could see the I could see it and I think
because it's only because I'm older that
I have the experience to recognize it
but if we were the same age [ __ ] man it
would go over my head too much but I see
his little gears turning and then I'm
like don't even think about it dude
because I because he goes Aha and I'm
like stop it nope cut it out we're going
that way
yeah damn
no I didn't hate myself in high school
I just hated High School I hated myself
in that high school because the high
school was so [ __ ] dope but you liked
yourself and all the other ones because
you're like I'm dope
um
I don't know I just started to hate
myself a lot I just feel like I got into
a lot of trouble more and more and more
and I just started going from like
not maximizing High School to like where
the [ __ ] am I taking my life right now
whoa oh that's so deep
yeah I didn't hate myself I don't think
I ever hated myself
like I did want to uh I did have
Suicidal Thoughts but I never got close
to carrying that out
um but it wasn't because of me
it was because of just
my situation you know where I'm like
[ __ ] man I have nobody I'm so by myself
nobody understands me no one's even
trying to understand me no one even is
even listening to me everyone thinks the
worst of me I'm like [ __ ] man I how do I
get out of here
that was my only option
but I didn't hate myself
what else probably didn't get into the
kind of trouble I did I didn't
I got kicked out
two three high schools yeah because it
is different when your parents are just
saying that you're [ __ ] up versus the
rest of the world because with your
parents you can at least be like you are
tripping every I'm [ __ ] fine
everywhere else except here so it must
be you guys right I mean you're probably
not thinking that deeply but you don't
feel like everyone's telling you you're
a [ __ ] up I didn't have that I mean I
did have my parents telling me that but
everyone else around me wasn't saying
that yeah and also when you find
yourself in handcuffs you're like what
is going on when did you [ __ ]
handcuff
a lot I gotta rest a lot during that
whole period
how when for what
I don't remember you saying you're
getting like arrested in high school all
the time what yeah give it to me that's
when like how it went how for what
I mean like all the time like even like
even growing up in the sgv you get
hassled by cops uh this time I broke
into a house I got I was on my knees uh
the time I caught you and you broke in a
house yeah there's a I didn't know this
story
that was the reason that I got kicked
out of uh Cerritos High School because
you broke into this one we weren't even
breaking in uh to steal anything we were
just [ __ ] around having a good time
what do you mean you just were bored and
you're like I'm gonna go into that house
and see what snacks they have no so
there's there's this uh across the
street from cereals High School which is
Park called Heritage Park next to
Heritage Park there's a an abandoned
house that is commonly known to all the
people that went to Cerritos High School
so people would throw House Parties
there or do random things there because
they knew it was an abandoned house and
so one one day when I skipped school
um we decided oh let's go kick it over
there so we broke in we're kicking in at
the house waiting oh breaking in is
different I thought like people were
occupying this space that's what I'm
saying that's an abandoned house this
time
yeah and then uh one of my friends had
like bottle rockets so we're like oh
let's have bottle rocket fights so they
sound like guns obviously so we're like
just shooting each other in the backyard
and then I think the neighbors probably
call the cops because they probably
thought there was gunshots or whatever
yeah so the gun the the cops come and
then they
um and you're wearing baggy clothing and
all that yeah baggy clothing all that
stuff they kicked the door down they see
all of us we look like thugs and then uh
they had us on our knees and then you
did not look like a thug you look so
young
I'm in the clothes though you know oh I
see so you just look like a bad guy yeah
she put us on our knees all that stuff
and then uh and stick guns in our faces
and at this time like Asian gangs were
rampant got it so they also have Asian
gang units God I got it so they're just
like they have special extra high alert
and those guys are extra motivated put
guys like this away so they come in they
hassle us uh they found a knife on me oh
my God what the [ __ ] and then and then
uh during this time I guess they brought
me back to school and the principal
already had it out for me so I think his
way of kicking me out of school was
saying well if he had a knife on him
then during school hours if he would
have been at school
he would have had a knife on school
which is an expellable offense so that's
how he tied it together and he ended up
expelling me
from uh from school dang yeah that's
[ __ ] up instead of trying to help you
he's like I don't want to deal with this
problem get him out
but I also get it because he has a lot
of problems because he's got so many
kids yeah yeah
dang
no I can't relate dude
I just didn't like the people I didn't
like how people problem solved I didn't
like the bickering I didn't like what
they talked about like I had I couldn't
connect with anyone in school even like
my own friend circle like I loved them
and they were fun but I still felt like
I had to be a different person
to fit in and I don't like it I couldn't
wait to get out of high school I
couldn't wait to like
not be in that environment like when it
came to like being in like hey your
senior not the machine what the [ __ ] am
I talking about you're seeing your photo
senior citizen photo but yeah you're
seeing your photo like you go on a
weekend and like you get dressed up and
you like wear something specific and I'm
like I don't want to be in a [ __ ]
yearbook
like I don't even want to [ __ ] be
here why why don't you want to be there
you just feel like you're understood or
you just wasn't the right way to express
yourself I just felt like
I just felt like
um so out of place like I just felt like
everyone was so
um young in their brain
you know like the way they would like
what they found funny or what they found
exciting or like what was fun like it
was just so boring to me like it just
felt like they were all little kids
would you prefer to have been
homeschooled you think
if you go back [ __ ] no dude I wanted to
get out of the house so bad I was so
lonely what do you think would have been
the ideal situation for you then like if
you could go back in time like what
would how would you carry out your like
years 14 through 18.
um
so I don't know if if me feeling that
way is a result of me just feeling so
lonely
um or if it was just I was in the wrong
school because I don't know like your
school sounds fun as [ __ ] you know it
sounds like it had
um just so many different types of
people
um where mine just felt like it was just
a bunch of little kids so I guess maybe
going to a better school because I I
mean I wasn't academically
above anyone like I was average or maybe
even below average but again I don't
know if that's a result of me just being
so lonely that I didn't give a [ __ ]
about academic Academia that I'm like I
just wanna
be with [ __ ] warm Souls
yeah but I couldn't wait to leave I was
just like I hate it here did you like
volleyball because you played so many
years too it was fun that was fun did
you feel like that was kind of like your
tribe a little bit or not no not really
it was just it was fun for the
volleyball but it wasn't like I'm not
having deep conversations with anyone
like I'm not really connecting with
anyone like that because they were just
talking about boys and I liked boys
don't get me wrong but I wasn't as hung
up about it as like everyone else was
like I wasn't trying to be in a
relationship and I wasn't trying to talk
about drama and I wasn't trying to
gossip like I just it was just so boring
to me you think you would have liked it
more in like an art school or something
like a performing art school maybe but I
really wasn't an artist I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] show you know I did enjoy College
because now you have so many walks of
life you know so many different people
from all walks of life Community College
or a four-year four-year yeah Community
College just felt like another High
School oh I see you didn't feel like
yeah and I didn't I didn't hate that
though because now I I was picking you
know the route that I wanted to take I
was picking so many different things
so like it felt like okay I can control
it there's not bells that I have to like
from this time of this I'm like I felt
like an adult in control so I'd like
that oh yeah if I didn't want to go to
class I don't go to class if I wanted to
hang out and do some [ __ ] I'll do
some [ __ ] but
high school was just like bro I feel
like I'm getting stupid
you feel like you're getting stupid yeah
I just it was such a waste of time even
in class when you're learning [ __ ] you
weren't like oh I should better I wasn't
learning [ __ ] no because I'm just like
this is just so so stupid that's
probably why I'm a [ __ ] dumbass now
you know but
um at that time I'm just like what the
[ __ ] is all this maybe I was just
depressed that's what it sounds like it
sounds like you might have been
depressed so that uh you couldn't even
really figure out how to take it all in
maybe because like um
yeah no like we didn't even have school
spirit like that like we didn't have
like [ __ ] someone announcing [ __ ]
you know like it wasn't it was just like
a whatever school because I know I hated
school like this the studying part of it
but I always knew like I'm like oh I can
see how this is helpful like oh I could
see how English is important so that I
can like get my thoughts across better
and I'm not speaking dumb you know I I
don't speak good bad you know I'm like
you don't want to sound like that so I
get that and in history I'm like oh I
should probably know how the world
operates because then if you learn like
what we what kind of mistakes we made in
the past then we know how to create a
better future but I'm like why can't I
just get myself to enjoy it you know so
I understood like a lot of [ __ ] yeah
like or even like in PE right where
you're like like trying to see if you
can touch your toes I'm like oh I can
see why like you want to be kind of
flexible I could see why you want to be
able to run a mile and not feel like
you're about to die I get it but why
can't I get myself to do the things that
are supposed to be good for me that's
the part I didn't understand and I think
that's the part I hated myself for I see
where I see all the [ __ ] nerds just
[ __ ] going oh yeah I PE time I'm
gonna run and run my best you know yeah
yeah yeah I'm like what the [ __ ] man no
maybe I was depressed
yeah maybe I was depressed because I'm
just like
um I just wanted to connect with anyone
and I just felt like I couldn't connect
with anyone
yeah so I was just like I didn't give a
[ __ ] about why I was doing any of that
because I'm like
what's the [ __ ] point I enjoyed
history there were certain topics I'd
enjoyed you know I definitely enjoyed it
there were teachers that I enjoyed there
were some people that I thought were
cool like obviously my friend Circle was
cool but it just felt like I had to like
like lower a lot of myself not like oh
I'm so smart but just I had to suppress
a lot of it because I'm just like I'm I
don't relate to a lot of you guys right
now so like I have to like be with you
guys and whatever you guys are talking
about whatever you guys find is fun
because I'm like this is not fun
scholarships whack
what's fun to you now
uh like at this age what's fun to me now
um I like building so like business is
fun to me
right like zooming out a lot business is
fun to me because I get to build [ __ ]
and I'm I'm a builder and I like
building
um I like creating things I like seeing
things go from like just an idea to like
a physical thing like I like I like that
process I like working for the sake of
um the build so I enjoy it I really do
enjoy it I enjoy being outdoors I enjoy
having really deep conversations with
people I enjoy learning about people
like people really fascinate me you know
um how they problem solve what they
think how they view the world like all
that stuff so fascinating so like that's
why like even with business it's so
fascinating how people build it because
it's all it's all the thought process
right it's just a trial and error like
I'm thinking this so I'm gonna try this
I try this [ __ ] I collect my data [ __ ]
let me think of something else okay and
now I'm gonna apply it let me collect
that data oh [ __ ] it succeeded let me
repeat that or whatever but it still
comes from a person and I think people
are so interesting
you think you would have liked maybe
building a business in high school be
one of those guys like a high school
entrepreneur I think so I
had a lot of fun
yeah maybe it was just like the uh
the task at hand wasn't stimulating
enough maybe
maybe I mean or it could just be I was
[ __ ] depressed and so lonely
yeah I was so lonely man like I I can't
stress that enough like my older brother
my older sister minimum 10-year Gap
um my little sister six year Gap and
then my parents are both working I my
you know the area that I grow up in is
like they're not allowed out I can't
leave like past my Gates so I just
stayed indoors all day did you have a
best friend in high school yeah
I had a best friend in high school did
you guys talk and connect hard or no for
sure but I felt like there was and it
this is probably coming for me too there
was always like a wall like we couldn't
really get too vulnerable like now yeah
maybe it's I don't know how to get
vulnerable so I pick people that also
don't know how to get vulnerable so like
it wasn't very um it wasn't very deep
you know like it was we we gelled really
well
I mean it could all be me you know but
it just didn't feel like if I lost this
person I'm devastated like I just lost
my best friend
you know when we parted ways I was just
like okay and we parted ways not on bad
terms
um but it's just life took us in
different directions and I'm like I
don't want to go in that direction I
want to go my direction and I just went
in my direction
and then you know we just stopped
talking more and more we hung out with
different people and I'm like I'm cool
with that
in that wild
yeah who knows I'm such a weird you were
you were lonely because you don't even
have a best friend during that time I
didn't have your siblings I mean that's
not a real best friend yeah but that
just that was just out of her friends
they were the best but that wasn't a
best friend yeah no I didn't have like
that well I felt like I couldn't even
really build that I just maybe I just
don't know how to connect properly you
know yeah
um or like usually you go through some
[ __ ] that makes you become best friends
like you're
stealing some [ __ ] and something happens
is that you guys get like you guys Bond
more but because I was on such lockdown
like the the time I could spend with
people like we didn't really get to
experience a lot or this could all just
be my own in my own brain
yeah so like whenever people I just was
never attached to anyone
I don't know
wild right yeah it's crazy
yeah I was never like oh that's my best
friend I want the best friend I was just
like hey I'm cool being a lone wolf
or alone whatever you want to call me
like it was okay
are you cool being that now
um
I'm pretty cool being that now
yeah what you don't really hear me say
like oh I wish this and I want to do
that and whatever
like I'm pretty chill maybe on low
maintenance no I might not but I'm I'm
your best friend now yeah
and we have pretty deep conversations we
talk all the [ __ ] time about
everything yeah
damn you're crazy what's crazy because I
had so many best friends yeah that it's
car it's hard for me to imagine not
having one for so long all of high
school I had people
with and like they were my people you
know like I just we hang out all the
time like that's not that's not that's
all surface [ __ ] yeah then I guess I
only had surface relationships I'm
talking about like
someone socks you in the face no
questions asked they jump out of their
Channel or being the [ __ ] out of the
other person oh I don't know if that I
don't know we it was never tested but
you know it though just from other
little scenarios you know it I had
girlfriends like that
and then you could talk about anything
and if you need to run away from home
they'll you go to their house and you
know they'll cover up for you and if
your mom tries to call their house
they'll cover it up for you yeah
that's pretty tight then yeah why do you
feel like you're still alone
um I just didn't feel like uh like a
deep connection you know maybe I'm
searching for something that's
impossible
who knows but like yeah I just didn't
feel like I I because isn't a really
isn't like a friendship something where
at least for best friends where it's
like
you need that person around like they're
just part of your life
or they get you
and you get them
um maybe just that maybe maybe and it
makes everything better
hmm
maybe they didn't get me maybe I didn't
even get myself like something happens
like oh man this pizza's good oh they
gotta try I gotta try with them
I got something dope happened like I'd
rather do it by myself
I don't remember feeling like that
like that wow I know no I'm a [ __ ]
weirdo damn that's crazy what about now
do you if you try something bomb do you
go like oh papa has to try this of
course I tell you all the time well
that's cute like I'd rather not do it to
save it so that we can do it together
because I'm like oh I already know
that's kidney yeah I don't know or maybe
I was just so
um
I was so lost in myself and not knowing
who the [ __ ] I was that like I just kind
of like or maybe I just didn't even
understand [ __ ] friendship
interactions who knows because I was so
lonely you know that I didn't know that
like this is this is the pattern of
friendship you tell secrets you open up
You're vulnerable or what the [ __ ] is
even vulnerable you know maybe it could
have been all that and maybe it's me
just having all these walls up or just
not even knowing
that that's what is supposed to
transpire between
two different people
wild right because like in junior high I
had a best friend and we would talk for
[ __ ] hours on the phone and stuff but
even then it was like we would just talk
stupid [ __ ] and it's like little kid
stuff you know I mean you can't get too
deep in your [ __ ] throat of course
yeah so like that's why I didn't feel
like and then when we went to high
school it just felt like we were just
very different people from two different
walks of life because she's Asian and
her parents wanted her to be super like
that super innocent like they kind of
act like little kids like even till this
day like we connected
um
I probably haven't talked to her in a
couple years now but
um when I tried connecting with her
again I was like whoa you're still a
little kid like you're I don't know just
felt like her her like she was just kind
of stunted
you know like emotionally like
she just liked collecting like little
kid things and like was still that
little girl that I knew back then but
she was like now she has a career woman
you know and she was gonna be a mom and
I was like whoa this is weird like you
stayed kind of like young wow yeah so I
was like I don't know I like I feel like
you're still that little kid you know
when I talk to you you're still
complaining about the same thing and I'm
like this is what we got we've we can't
be friends like I like I have like I
know her but I'm like this is not
someone I want to hang out with and like
have a vulnerable conversation with
because you sound so young
wild right yeah yeah
that's crazy I know I don't know maybe I
take off after my mom my mom's the same
way oh yeah she told me uh you know when
I go visit on the weekends when I go
like shoot JK news I'm living with your
mom I always talk to her and I'm like
hey like uh do you feel lonely or do you
like like the way it is she goes I
actually really like the way my
Arrangement is right now yeah I'm like
you like living by yourself she goes
yeah I wake up I do the stuff that I
want uh makes me happy she's like
especially like growing up you know when
you're a mom you live your life for your
children or you live your life for your
husband and it feels like for once I get
to really live my life for myself and I
really like it and I'm like wow yeah
that's crazy yeah I don't know if it's
also like
maybe like a a person that feels big
emotions
you know maybe like we just get
exhausted and we're introverted yeah
because we do feel a lot of people's
energies like right off the bat
and I married a weird one
oh says the [ __ ] guy over here that
[ __ ] look at you like what are you
doing with your hands what's going on
you're super weird what do you mean this
is the the croissant hands exactly we're
both [ __ ] weird people and why is
that weird what me not feeling like I
need a lot of people I don't know you're
a loser in high school was I a loser I
know a lot of people a lot of people
knew me not like yours though yeah I
think you're very popular you're a loner
yeah I don't think I was popular at all
but a lot of people knew you they knew
me but not for good things it was just
the guys okay you're notorious that's so
popular yeah I'm more I'm more of a
notorious mechanic than I am a [ __ ]
right but they're still popular
regardless
well popular is like Everyone likes you
okay fine so you're notorious I don't
know if people like me they just know I
was the guy that probably lived at the
principal's office yeah fine well yeah
you're notorious
I don't know man I'm a [ __ ] weird
person
I'm a Loner
I don't know if I hate that though do
you like friends when you're a kid
what does that mean like taika you know
he loves me playing with friends
I don't think he's a loner yeah
because he he would really much rather
be with people and like do things than
to just go off to the corner and just do
his own thing that's the
house with with other siblings
I don't get stories told about how I was
as a kid because I don't remember
yeah like you have so many stories
because your mom only remembers you
because she only had you right the same
way I can only think of taika's stuff
and I can remember everything but if I
were to ask like my brother he's gonna
be like wait I think that's what he wait
was that him or was that him or like am
I mixing up my stories am I mixing my
kids
it all kind of just becomes this one
little thing so yeah I don't know how I
was as a kid oh wow no clue I have no
stories to share well what about just
from your own experience though do you
remember going like oh man I really
wanted to play with kids when I was a
kid
I did I really wanted to play with kids
when I was a kid I did I remember there
was this chick that lived in the
apartments next to where I grew up and
um her name was Joanna My Name Is Jovana
and then I always wanted to play with
her so bad because we were the same age
and she was the only other little girl
on my block and um and like since my
parents never let me go out like I would
just see her in passing I'm like [ __ ] I
wish I was her friends and I do remember
like rare instances where the
neighborhood kids would come over to my
house and we did play and it was like
the coolest [ __ ] ever but I think that
only probably happened like once or
twice
yeah and I was like this is [ __ ]
Heaven you're back you're like can I
please go over again please I'm telling
you I was over I think that's why I
would have probably done better in
business like a school that focused on
entrepreneurship because I was always
trying to think of an angle of how to
get what I want while still giving in to
what like so if they give me a reason as
to why not then I try to find out what
is it that's preventing them from
wanting to do that and then I would try
to to like stick to that and then change
it right so if they were like your
safety you can't go here because you're
not going to be safe so I'm like huh
well what do you consider safe well and
then I would look at the patterns I'm
like okay so they think teachers are
safe they think school is safe cool so I
can get what I want if I if school
offers it so I'm like hey Mom I can
study abroad because it's a school
program they have all the school stuff
set up there you think school is safe
right yeah well then can I do that
through school it's still academic it's
safe no and I'm like [ __ ] so I'm always
trying to work an angle um yeah
kind of reminds me of this one time I
wonder if you would what you would do
but I remember this one time I was
supposed to meet up with one of my
friends and I think I was a freshman or
a sophomore in high school we're
supposed to meet up with them uh I
walked to his house and I found out he
wasn't home yet
so I was just like what should I do oh I
know what would be funny I'll break into
the house and then when they when him
and his parents come inside he'll be
like what you're already inside that's
crazy so I looked for any loose window
um and then I was like oh cool this uh
window upstairs looks cracked open so I
went on the side you know boundary wall
then I jumped on the roof and then I
opened the window I popped the screen
door open Slide the glass door go inside
and then uh when they pulled up they uh
I heard them use the keys to open the
front door I got open and I was like
and then uh the mom was like you need to
go home right now
and never talk to Brian again
and I was like oh
what and you're like yeah you're not
welcome here ever again whoa and I was
like
and I and at that time I felt like I
just made a new best friend because uh
that's when uh some of us in Drumline
were getting really tight so I started
hanging out with him any way more and we
started having all kinds of sleepovers
and stuff
and uh that like crushed me and I
remember going home and then calling
like maybe like a week later like hey
Brian is it for reals I can't come over
because yeah I'm not even supposed to be
talking to you on the phone right now
and that really destroyed um my
relationship with him
and I'm like [ __ ] that sucks so what
part are you wondering what I would do
like let's say you come home and then as
an adult yeah with taika and then in
taika's high school friend broke into
her house what would you do well I don't
I mean obviously I don't know the extent
of how much [ __ ] you did prior to
this because that's just your memory and
that's the one that you remember right
but I don't know if there's a pattern of
already a bunch of [ __ ] he already
got in trouble in school because he is
hanging out with you so I don't know
that history I don't think so if it was
one I was just sleeping over at Brian's
house all the time yeah I'm pretty sure
she saw a lot of your [ __ ] and maybe
that was like the straw that broke the
camel's back right
um so I'll assume for your for for this
scenario that it's the first time yeah
um and I just met you I think I would
have a conversation with you and be like
you know that what you did is not right
it's not correct and then I would
probably try to talk to you I don't know
if I would say you can't see this person
ever again
but I have a feeling I have a really big
strong feeling that she already saw what
type of kid you are and how you think
and she probably didn't want you around
her kid because you're sleeping over so
much she's probably picking up on all
these patterns you're probably talking a
certain way you're probably being a
certain way you know what I mean I was
such a polite kid almost all parents
love me
you always tell me how like you're
always getting kicked out
kicked out of what like different
different like friend like parents are
telling you that's when I was in
elementary school once I got into high
school a lot of parents love me oh I see
then I don't know I I knew how to be
like uh very respectful and stuff like
that yeah and I was just way more polite
and I mean that's probably thanks to my
mom's upbringing yeah where like I was
probably more Korean than Koreans were
so I think a lot of like people are just
like oh this kid's really really
respectful and it's like always respect
like the rules of the house yeah it
seems kind of weird that it was just
that one instance and she's like never
again
it feels like maybe you just did a lot
of a lot of [ __ ] and she was like that I
can't do this this kid's gonna corrupt
my kid yeah yeah but if it was like a
troubled kid like that
um I don't know I I only know what my
mom did so I can only go based off of
that that's my Baseline you know so when
my mom didn't like the the girl that I
wanted to hang out with she'd be like
well who's gonna be there and that would
say and she's like I don't like that
girl you can't go and how old were you
guys High School
like 15. how does she know her
you know like my mom would pick me up
drop me off if she if she didn't know
what we were really gonna do she'd stay
there she's like [ __ ] it I'll sit in the
car if I need to all day just to watch
what's happening
my mom was not very trusting at all so
she knew every single one of my friends
she knew every single one of my friend's
parents like my mom was not an absent
she was highly involved she wasn't like
a [ __ ] what are they called the
helicopter parent she wasn't a
helicopter parent yeah but
um
when it came to just my safety she just
felt like come on dude the first time we
were gonna go [ __ ] to Paris our first
international flight she sent what was
that [ __ ] video she wanted me to
watch she's like watched this and it was
taken oh right taken yeah she's like
just prepare yourself because this is so
that's what her mind is I think you're
gonna be drugged and turned into a
brothel [ __ ] prostitute yeah yeah
yeah so now imagine me in high school
when I'm an extra hot commodity because
I'm like virgin blood she's like
probably she's like watching me as like
a [ __ ] hobby that was a good movie
though I'm glad she told us to watch it
it was a good movie but I'm like this is
so unrealistic yeah I like how we were
uh what were we like 23 or something 24.
for sure and then she was like watch
this yeah she's like prepare herself you
need to watch that and I'm like
and then when I watched it I was like oh
my God Mom it was [ __ ] cute yeah but
yeah in high school she knew she just
knew the lifestyle of the the my
friend's parents and like
their status and everything and what
they did for a living and stuff and
she's like I don't like I don't like how
they're raising that daughter and I want
you to be around her
that's pretty cool I mean now right as
I'm older I'm like thank you but then
I'm like what the [ __ ] you don't even
know she's so sweet yeah yeah
she's got my back no matter what yeah I
might have been the other kid but the
parents are like you need to stay the
[ __ ] away from my kid yeah if you're as
mischievous and getting if my mom found
out you got kicked out she'd be a no no
no no no like is Bart gonna be there you
can't hang out
I haven't got that from my own uncle
in elementary school and I was getting
in so much trouble my mom's brother yeah
like when I would go visit in Taiwan
like I don't want your kid around my kid
for my own Uncle yeah I feel like tyke
is going to get in that space and I'm
like damn like we're family though how
close-minded right I'm like damn that's
[ __ ] crazy yeah it's that to me is a
huge so I get both sides the first one
is especially ten you know especially
that's what I was about to say
especially when you're in that that
highly influential phase which would be
like Junior High about to enter High
School yeah I would start guiding my kid
to like nah that's bad news you can't
you know and obviously they're going to
want to do it even more but I would
really try to have that conversation of
like hey you need to pick and choose
your friends wisely but anything younger
than that I'm like it ain't that big of
a deal what the [ __ ] I can handle my
kids
but anyone older I'm like oh [ __ ]
they're going into that I this is my
life I do what I want phase and it's
like oh [ __ ] I remember that phase
I'm like I thought I knew not everything
I was never that stupid but I thought
like I see the world differently than my
parents and I'm like I think I know what
I'm talking about
it sounds like I knew everything huh
that's stupid I remember being at the
park and uh the one in uh LA and there's
this kid that was at the playground
playing with taika and he saw me and he
goes I watch our Vlogs and I'm like we
need to get the [ __ ] out of here why I
don't know I just didn't want to be like
um
I like it when like I feel like
everyone's on equal ground they're just
kids playing with kids I don't want oh
and the kid told that to take us well if
you watch my Vlogs and you watch tiger
and you know about taika's upbringing
and all that stuff I didn't want like
some guy to like show up even though
that kid's probably I don't know like
[ __ ] 10 or something I didn't want a
kid to come in like knowing all kinds of
like information about tiger for some
reason oh that's interesting then you
should not have him in Vlogs for this
whole [ __ ] life Bart
yeah I do want to Vlog I just don't want
to [ __ ] meet the weirdos that are
gonna say [ __ ] like that but that how do
you know they're a weirdo I could just
anyone that sees someone that goes I
watch your Vlogs it's [ __ ] weird
especially when you're a kid like that
his best friend says he watches him on
TV that's CUNY what the [ __ ] what's the
difference because that's his best
friend and they go to the same school
so that's if it makes sense in your head
fine that's CUNY fine whatever but yeah
you [ __ ] married a weird person that
can be a total [ __ ] recluse hermit
[ __ ] completely isolated and I think
I'd be okay I think I might need
interaction maybe like once a month
where I'm like okay I need I need to
talk to someone and then I'm like okay
that's it I'm good
leave me alone
weird right yeah
maybe I went to the depths of my brain
as I was [ __ ] so lonely in my room I
think my room was probably this size
yeah I think my room is probably this
size but I had a king-sized bed because
my guest I guess my dad got a [ __ ]
deal uh so every room had a king-sized
bed or either that or he paid full price
for it because then he probably thought
his brothers and [ __ ] would sleep over I
don't know I don't know what it was but
yeah so eighty percent of my room was a
bed and then I just had this little
strip because I had a big ass [ __ ]
what are they called like a dresser
dresser yeah
um so I had like this little strip and I
remember I would exercise there and then
like my my closet had those mirror
slider doors and I would just practice
makeup or like just teenager [ __ ] you
know like I would decorate my room all
day but I was just there
my whole life
sounds sad
and you grew up with a really [ __ ] up
childhood how dare you called my [ __ ]
said well at least I did the right thing
and I would sneak out right away from my
home run away from home and experience
life
you know I would like leave at like
midnight yeah I would like set little
alarms so I could wake up and then like
maybe your parents messed up by living
in a safe neighborhood and you're a dude
so it's also different because I was not
in a safe neighborhood and I'm a chick
and I maybe I was just a little [ __ ]
but I'm like uh-uh a lot of people want
this ass
and that's not even true but like that's
in my head I'm like they want young girl
ass I just needed to get out
I can I can stay boxed in like that I
need to get out somehow yeah you're
brave because I was just like the only
time I ever snuck out was once and I was
20.
three maybe 24. yeah that's what I
realized about rebellious kids if you
don't give them what they want it's
gonna be worse you know so if all they
want to do is go to a school dance you
might as well do that because if not
they're gonna go raving and do drugs
you know what I mean so I think that's
that's that's where it's like oh uh
you're not gonna let me like play sports
in high school then I'm just gonna go
fight on the streets like you know it's
like that kind of stuff damn yeah you
don't let me like hang out then when I
sneak out I'm gonna do all kinds of
drugs and smoke weed and do whatever you
know yeah play with friends in my head
[ __ ] you yeah damn
all right well we got a lot to look
forward to don't we yeah well I'm really
happy that we had such interesting
childhoods
um and we felt so like
um
like not belonging because I think
that's really a great sign where that's
those are some things that we really
care about so the minute we see that
taika has those signs we know what to do
you know yeah probably you more than me
no you you're the loser
wait you got kicked out of everything
he's here too no you're a loner loser
fine you're a [ __ ] popular Loser yeah
all right Loser yeah we're both losers
but at least I was a cool Loser yeah I
was never you're a loner loser I am
alone and no one liked I was an artsy
loner loser that like listening to
[ __ ] cool music and watching dope
movies yeah so I know so many [ __ ]
songs and [ __ ] movies I love it
I miss movies anyway on that note do you
have anything else to say [ __ ] loser
nope all right then well thank you guys
so much for watching and we'll see you
next week